what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be diving
into the latest developments
in the boku no hero story including the
fact that lately horikoshi seems to
really want to watch the whole world
burn deku and the top 4
pro heroes are currently in life
threatening danger
some of our favorite pro heroes may just
have died
at the hands of all for one and the
story just keeps getting darker and
darker
i was already heartbroken after what
happened to lady nagant in the previous
chapter
and now things have escalated even more
very quickly
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
pocono hero content here on the channel
and you want to see more be sure to
leave a like
and comment it only takes a second and
it's a totally free way to support
the channel and of course if you're new
to animeopro or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain boku do hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with
caution you have been warned okay so we
ended up
last time with lady nagant literally
exploding because of some devious master
plan that all for one had set
into motion and just as she was about to
fall to the ground
hawks appeared and rescued her then we
see endeavour
arriving on the scene as well and it
seems that hawks and endeavour were able
to find deku because
all might called them and told them
where deku was
because his wings are still severely
injured hawks
is not yet able to fly properly and he
almost crashes to the ground
with lady nagant in his arms but
thankfully deku reaches out with black
whip and grabs them
and then he uses float to keep all of
them from falling
although it definitely isn't easy for
deku to pull this off because he is
almost completely worn out from his
battle with lady nagant
deku's theory is that all for one
somehow booby-trapped the quirk that he
gave to lady nagant
and that is why she ended up exploding
exactly when he wanted her to
this is a very interesting development
because if all for one is able to
straight up booby traps the quirks that
he transfers to other people
then he might have even more control of
shigaraki than we realized
think about it even if all for one fails
to take over shigaraki's body
he may have booby-trapped his body so
that if he ever decides to go against
all for one shigaraki will be blown to
pieces by the booby traps
at this point i'm not sure if this
really was some sort of booby trap that
old for one can attach to literally any
quirk
or if he secretly transferred some sort
of explosion quirk
into lady nagant without her knowledge
but either way this is definitely the
type of
evil genius stuff that we have come to
expect from all for one
he really doesn't leave anything to
chance and he always wants to be
several steps ahead of his enemies as we
will see later on in the chapter
this trend of all for one staying a step
ahead is going to continue
or is it more on that later as the two
of them are lowered down to the ground
by deku
hawkes tries to speak to lady nagant he
tells her that he is her successor in
the hero public safety commission
and then he chides her for letting
herself be manipulated by all for one
it is clear that hawks has a huge amount
of respect for lady nagant
and he doesn't want to accept that she
is letting herself be used as a tool for
the villains
hawks reminds lady nagant that she is a
hero at heart
and he tells her to tell him everything
she knows about all for one and his
plans
in that moment lady nagant appears to
regain consciousness
so that means that she is thankfully
still alive let's hope it stays that way
it seems that lady nagant and hawks
don't actually know each other from
before
i kind of assume that they knew each
other after hawks called her
senpai and i thought that he may have
trained directly under her
at some point however it seems that
hawks was only referring to her as
senpai
in the formal sense she was his senior
in the organization but she was not his
friend or mentor
lady nagant knows that as her successor
hawks must have been forced to do all
sorts of horrible things by the hero
public safety commission
and yet just like deku hawks still has
that heroic
fire in his eyes lady nagant doesn't
understand how this is possible
how can hawks maintain a heroic spirit
after all the darkness that he must have
seen
how can he still want to be a hero after
realizing that the people who were
running the entire hero society were no
better than villains themselves
hawks simply smiles and replies that at
the end of the day
he is an optimist and he also had
someone who supported him and that seems
to be a reference to endeavour
and the inspiration that hoggs drew from
endeavour ever since he was a child
lady nagant then proceeds to reveal all
for one's plans at least
a part of them she says that in the next
two months
the target deku was to be taken to a
mansion
in haiburi forest and lady nagant says
something
else too along with her all for one
recruited multiple
other people additional villains that we
are sure to meet
in the near future we see the
silhouettes of these villains but we
don't get to see their face or their
quirks or anything else about them
definitely let me know down in the
comments who you think these villains
are are these skps from tartarus and the
other prisons
or are they maybe international villains
from outside of japan
we know that the heroes are calling in
reinforcements from other countries
so could all for one be doing the same
thing i'm sure that the world beyond
japan
is full of interesting and overpowered
villains and heroes
so it would definitely be extremely cool
to meet some of them in the story
as hawks speaks to lady nagant about all
for one's plans
endeavour grabs overhaul and brings him
down from the roof
as you might imagine overhaul is
extremely upset because he doesn't want
to be taken away by the heroes he was
promised an opportunity to see his boss
again and he is desperate to see his
boss and to apologize to him
in person this seems to be overhaul's
singular remaining goal in life
and he is straight up hysterical about
seeing it through to the end
with so much emphasis being placed on
overhaul and his relationship with the
yakuza boss
i feel like we're definitely gonna get
more of his backstory sometime soon
we do know some very general information
about him and how the boss took him in
when he was still just a kid
but there must be more to his story my
theory about overhaul's backstory
is that when he was a young boy his
father took him into the city to see a
marching band
but that's just a theory we'll have to
wait and see but yeah
overhaul is just freaking out on deku
and asking him to see the boss over and
over again and that's when deku just
calmly looks at him and asks him
do you remember what you did to eddie
chan deku believes that overhaul should
want to apologize to arie
the same way that he wants to apologize
to his boss and deku then informs
overhaul that he will be the one to keep
the promise that lady nagant had
made deku will take over hall to see
his boss okay deku cool story bro but i
really hope that your plan here is to
actually make use of overhaul
in the fight against all for one if deku
really just wants to help overhaul out
of the goodness of his heart after
everything that overhaul has done
then deku must have a superhuman
capacity for forgiveness
i don't think that any of us readers are
even close to being ready to forgive
overhaul for what he did to arie
i understand being a hero and wanting to
help people but overhaul does not
deserve help he might be useful to the
heroes in the long run he does have an
extremely powerful quirk
but he definitely hasn't earned anyone's
forgiveness or compassion
not even close but that is when all
might shows up
and it looks like our boy hercules is
actually okay
he's a little bruised and banged up but
he's still functional
and that is a huge relief look i know
that a lot of people really love
the going merry in one piece but you
know what i think hercules is just
as awesome i'm only kidding one piece
fans okay
don't kill me i do prefer the thousand
sunny though anyway endeavour says that
he has secured lady in a gauntlet
overhaul
and that he will inform the police and
take the villains to a hospital for
treatment
hawks tells deku that he's also hurt and
he should also go to the hospital
clearly hawks still doesn't know deku
deku's thoughts are already on all for
one
and in the very next scene we see a
bunch of the heroes approaching a
mansion
in highbury forest the very same mansion
that lady nagant had talked about
earlier the heroes that we see on the
scene include deku
endeavor hawks best genius headshot
kamui woods
and mount lady it seems that some time
has passed between these two scenes
i'm not sure if it was like two months
like lady nagant had mentioned earlier
or if it was less than that but to me
this feels like it's happening pretty
soon after the lady nagant fight
this doesn't feel like a multiple month
time skip but we'll have to wait and see
either way we now have the top 4 pro
heroes
all here in one place together with deco
and some other heroes
these heroes are really going all in on
the mansion attack and if anything were
to happen to all of them at once
it's safe to say that all hope would be
lost for the hero society
but at the same time i can definitely
understand why they are choosing to take
this risk time is not on their side
and they have to act before shigaraki's
procedure is perfected
and before all for one finds a way to
steal a one for all
so even though this is a very risky
operation
the heroes must feel that it's now or
never
once they enter the mansion they don't
actually find anyone there
the only thing that greets deku and
endeavour inside the mansion
is a video of all for one although i do
believe that it is a live
feed all for one anticipated that the
heroes would find
this place but for their part the heroes
seem to have also expected that the
mansion would be empty
all for one then goes on a rant about
the hero society and how it is a
controlled
society it doesn't matter whether the
society is a democracy or a dictatorship
because whenever someone doesn't meet
the definition of a productive member of
society
they are just labeled as villains and
excluded from society as
a whole there is no such thing as real
justice
those who are in power simply decide
what justice is
and when someone doesn't fit their
definition of justice they label them as
villains and
ostracize them from society all for
one's speech here reminds me a bit of
thrasymachus
in plato's republic and those of you who
have taken political theory courses in
school might know what i'm talking about
all for one then tells deku that he is
no longer interested in all might
because he is now primarily interested
in deku himself
as all for one's projection points at
deku and says
you're next mirroring the way that all
might had said you're next to deku way
back in kamino
a massive blast rocks the forest and
absolutely
incinerates the entire mansion and that
is how this
dark and explosive chapter ends
whoa what just freaking happened
did that explosion really go off while
the heroes were all still
inside the mansion or is this just a
misdirection and maybe the explosion
actually happened sometime later
meaning that the heroes had time to
escape but maybe they just made all for
one thing that he blew them up
if the blast really happened right in
that very moment while the heroes were
inside
i'm sure that some of the heroes like
deku endeavor and ed shot will have the
ability to escape due to their
insane speed but heroes like say comey
woods and mount lady would have a
tougher time surviving such
a massive sudden explosion we better
hope that those guys didn't enter the
mansion along with declan endeavour
and that they kept their distance i'm
telling you guys right now
i am not ready to see another waifu get
seriously hurt
or worse come we would he's okay right
he's cool but
mount lady is one of the first waifus
that mha
ever blessed us with don't do this to me
horikoshi
don't do it man okay let me know what
you guys thought about this
chapter personally i think it's just
been one fire chapter
after another in these past few weeks do
you guys think that any of the heroes
were really injured or maybe even killed
in that explosion or do you think that
the explosion might have taken place
later and the heroes were able to escape
also
who were those shadowy villains that all
for one has gathered around him
are these people that we've met before
or are they entirely
new characters finally what do you guys
think about how dark the story
has been getting and do you think that
all for one has a point when he says
that there is no such thing
as real justice those who are in power
just decide what justice is
they make a definition that suits them
and their own interests
and then they label anyone who disagrees
with them as villains or criminals and
so on
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this bokudo hero video
and you want to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
upper patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to the absolute mad
lad and biggest lifetime donator
alpha sigma disciple of lord twego
himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algertol dr cortman the toasted chi
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis
faked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red haired raven on hell
crews anatoly kazatsuki very gucci
alicia octor bonnie park sino kamir
water joy and garcia ted no ted fat boy
games
corey mcgowan metal mama deadly saint
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you